hello and welcome to Moses and Friends I
am America's least tipped cam boy Moses
storm the music you heard up top a band
that's gonna be with us the whole time
through this thing is strange hotels you
can find them on Spotify strange hotels
what a great time to be a band name
strange hotels very comforting yeah
we'll have them back and yeah we'll put
a link up somewhere now if you haven't
seen this show before because we have
never done one before this is the show
where we take all of our favorite people
from the Konan world and the show and we
put them up in your living room we used
to be a live thing we did on stage but
we thought hey how do we make it worse
how do we make it less fun let's put it
in a living room there's a lucky for me
though there's two great guests on the
show that's gonna make this show not
terrible jenny zigrino and joel kim
booster they'll be on in just a second
but this is what live performing is now
this is 2020 live performing for the
foreseeable future it's this you could
do this or the other thing this is a
very real thing that comedians are doing
right now they're performing in parking
lots and cars will pull up and when they
like a joke
they will honk at you honk honk you know
the universal sound for [ __ ] you get the
[ __ ] out of the way
feels like my dream feels like why I got
into it a lot of people like the
applause and the laughter as a
substitute for real love and a bad
childhood
I like the honks I like feeling like I
almost got in a car accident
every time I joke or you can do this you
can do these these online shows which we
won't be doing we won't be doing
stand-up on these shows what we'll be
talking to funny people and that will
hopefully be a little bit better because
I've been watching the zoom shows I
thought with this time I would learn
Spanish I have learned no Spanish what I
have done is formed a morbid fascination
with watching zoom comedy shows and they
all go something like this this is every
zoom set ok ok you want me to go now I'm
on now all right
okay okay yeah okay all right here we go
this is weird
so I've been thinking about how um how
one of the unlikely heroes is bred for
this whole thing cause like you go back
to January and no one was like if I come
out of here right no bread and then now
that I get everyone everyone's everyone
a making bread Greg wow this is so weird
okay Oh someone's in the chat they're
saying why would any human being do this
to themselves this is uh okay let's see
my apartment that's the oh my roommates
do not want me to be doing this and
they're like they're worried I'm a babe
pay rent it's not do you wanna see my
dog
so the rough so we won't do that but but
this this will be fun because we have to
do this because we don't want to get
honked at and we don't want to do zoom
so we're here and then we're live in the
chat so you can cyberbully me in real
time if you've ever wanted to heckle a
comedian with complete anonymity it's a
win-win you go for it it's fun now we're
doing this because we're going into
another lockdown which is very confusing
cookies we're also in Phase three of
reopening America if you're not familiar
with the phases of every opening America
phase one is we open select retail
stores but with face coverings masks
which has been going just great footage
phase two was we open restaurants but
with social distancing with the safest
measures possible like this group of
people in Chicago um I love I love
brunch so much I love the smell of eggs
benedict and my own breath and all my
friends breath this is fun what's that
to go box no I'm gonna throw everything
in the bag slink it over my shoulder
because me me peg person and in this
phase three and that's what we're in now
phase three of reopening America is
where we all collectively just pretend
kovetz not real because we're bored it's
just boring
I really did man boring
I get it you don't want to do another
lockdown right it sucks why would we do
another lockdown the first lockdown
didn't work yeah
first lockdown didn't work because we
never did a first lockdown we closed
some places but not all the places and
we're all one place whether you like it
or not bring this together a good way to
think about it I guess would be okay so
America is a sinking ship right covered
in holes taking on a lot of water and
our one plan was like okay well let's
just cover this one New York size hole
Montana could you help we're taking out
a lot of water in Montana was like I'm
not helping there's no holes on my side
in Florida was like don't worry I'll
drain all the water out by creating more
holes and people don't want to wear
masks that's what's also delaying things
I get it you don't want to wear a mask I
also don't want to wear a mask it
[ __ ] sucks in there I've hung out
with my own mouth it's a miracle
that any human being has ever agreed to
kiss this it is so gross I've been
hanging out with this hot wet it breeds
it stinks it's your mouth just like this
place like open wound with teeth if you
ever looked at an open wound doing how
didn't make this grosser put teeth in it
that's your mouth but the the
honest-to-god truth is the longer you
don't wear a mask the longer you're
gonna have to wear a mask I think the
only way to get Americans to wear a mask
is if we deep-fry them it's the only
time we do anything that's healthy for
us I don't want what's that chicken
breasts zucchini
yuck deep-fry it zucchini fries and
fried chicken YUM we deep-fry the masks
then you no longer hear the argument
that's like okay well no why you trying
to step on my liberties not people like
oh my god have you tried the new and 95
sour cream and onion it crunch that's my
idea for Shark Tank that's the new
season I
okay so this is
been watching the most recent season of
shark tank and I want to hear your
thoughts so put this in the chat I've
been watching the most recent season but
the season was recorded in in 2019
before everything went
how'd you phrase whoopsie-daisy so all
these businesses small businesses
they're on Shark Tank and they're so
confident they the Sharks no idea what's
coming
sharks get ready to invest we've had a
great year and in 2020 it only gets
better in 2020 we're gonna expand to 57
locations in gross 90 million dollars
per lokay and I'm just watching this
like well no you [ __ ] won't but best
of luck on your buffet slash massage
business called pork shoulders hope it
works out I do wonder what like they
have to do another season right Shark
Tank it's like their number one show
what what what are the businesses in
2021 episodes of shark tank what are
those like so put those in the chat
that's what I want to see what's a
business that's gonna do well that's
like hey sharks are you tired of your
water constantly being on fire